Okay, welcome to another Zoom call. It is the 17th August and as I remind you on every Zoom call,
it's a story minor just because we have new people all the time joining these. If you have
questions that you don't want to wait till the Zoom call, feel free to look on our blog on our website.
Now, we don't have this search piece on our member site with that little search thing right there on
the website. You can search for your topic and we may have created a page. I may have created a
blog. I may have created a video over the years that may answer your question and that will help just
you with your with your question, hopefully. We have a member's site. If you are not on the member's
site, you probably aren't on this Zoom call. So you really don't need to talk about that, but everybody
should go and use the member site if you will please to make sure that you see any any new
information. So we have announcements on the member site all the time. So make sure you look for those
announcements. That should be your first go to. If you have questions and you want to communicate with
us that you go to the member site and you could put in a question on the member site, we have two Zoom
calls a week. Remember, and Zoom call on Mondays at noon, and my Zoom call here that you're on today.
So and then if you do ask the question on the member site, then it goes in to the PowerPoint key note
presentation that we're going to get at right now. So here's a question and it was kind of big. So I
had to do it in a smaller phone and let's go through it. General question regarding CT scans and
how accurate they are. I have had three CT scans of the pelvic area now for a colorectal tumor.
Two with contrasted one without I'm using these to measure progress. The only problem is that they're
very inconsistent. I've had several MRIs done as well. All done since March 11, 2022. First scan,
estimated like 4.7 centimeters. Second scan, with contrast, the radiologist said no change. Third scan,
more recently, the radiologist said 6.3 centimeters. No is 6.1 6.3 centimeters, no 6.7 centimeters.
We've talked about a four millimeter difference there. In reviewing the MRI, nowhere in the
summary, did they mention length? Per the oncologist, this is very slow growing cancer. So I suspect that it will
that it went from 4.7 to 7, 6.7, and I am sure how they determine the 6.3 in the previous measurement.
Maybe the radiologist re-measured the first scan since this was never mentioned in any of the other
reports. This is somewhat frustrating in trying to measure progress with my colors clinical. Good news
is here were two to three suspect pelvic lymph nodes, the biggest one was 9 millimeters, now 7
millimeters, others did not change. So I've sent multiple times that even though CT scans and
PET scans and MRIs are the gold standard of measuring progress in masses in the body,
at some point in history should the Lord Terry we're going to look back and laugh at this technology.
The reason is that you're still looking at a not just a three-dimensional object, you're looking at
a multi-dimensional object that is tissue that changes shape and size, possibly on a daily basis,
and certainly something in your colon that is going to change even with food passing through it,
and then you're trying to make an assessment to whether there's progress or not.
That's it is very inaccurate. I mean if you just think about it from a physical standpoint,
you have to argue with the inaccuracy of the test. So what you have to do is kind of take it in
gross understanding, meeting like, okay, if it was measured at 4.7 centimeters at one point in time
and it was now 12 centimeters. Okay, that's a change. There's obviously a large enlargement,
but if it was 6.3, that's now 6.7, what's the variability of inaccuracy in this test when you're
looking at a multi-dimensional object? I mean, you could have been laid in the scan a little bit different
that your guts are in a little bit different position. The cancer is in a totally different position
though you're looking at it completely differently. Where are they measuring from
in the first scan compared to the second scan? There's just a lot of inaccuracies. You're really looking
for gross changes. So yes, if the cancer hasn't gotten any bigger, well, then it's not continuing to rapidly
replicate. Remember, the definition of cancer is the fact that these cells are in rapid replication.
If it hasn't gotten significantly larger, then you've got to go, okay, well, at least something
is happening that either cells are dying or there's a decrease in the rapid replication.
You're decreasing the rate of rapid replication, so it is all good. Unfortunately, it's still
considered the gold standard, but what I say is with every test, you have to measure every test and
balance it with other findings. So you look at subjective and other objective findings.
So if I had a scan like this, oh, there's not that much change. I must be doing better. But
if my symptom pattern in a lot of different areas has gotten worse, my fatigue is worse,
my I have shortness of breath quite upstairs now. And my maybe some other objective findings are changing
by red blood cell coaches dropping, my hemoglobin is dropping. Well, then I wouldn't be real
encouraged that the CT scan is showing, quote, unquote, positive results. If I'm having all sorts of
other negative subjective and or objective findings. So you balance out any subjective or objective
findings with other subjective and objective findings in order for you to gather that information
and say, okay, I'm going to the right direction or I need to change directions in a little bit,
change my something to try to move in a better direction. So that's my opinion about any testing,
not just CTs, MRIs, PET scans or blood work. But anything you want to look at, sometimes a person
can feel much worse. But then all the other objective data is showing positive results. And sometimes
the person can have very poor objective data meeting. The scan is showing enlargement in every aspect.
But the person's like, oh, my gosh, my symptoms are gone and I'm feeling so much better. How can
this be that you that's what's called a pseudo negative change because sometimes when a when a tumor is
dying, it's your immune system is attacking it and you're getting a lot of inflammatory cytokines and
chemokines and just different types of white blood cells that are surrounding the tumor and it looks
larger on a scan. And that's what's called a pseudo enlargement. So that's a positive that's a
possibility too. And the only way you really truly know that is to look at other subjective and
objectable data. Success report, I wanted to share success by sister who is a chiropractor as a
graduate of at least one of Dr. Cutters continue education courses on his cancer protocol used to teach
doctors. Her husband was diagnosed back at March with stage 4 lung cancer are given four months to
live. Not sure if they could afford the cutters clinic, but she introduced me to Dr. Cutters website
around that same time. There are colleges recommended immunotherapy as a palliative treatment also
along with this with they obtained the right machine from a colleague and mounted a Tesla bulb
above where he sleeps and ray of the standard cancer programs, including the right tightly. Also,
they must have tested for various nutraceuticals and combined them for his program after three months
in a PET scan showing both tumors in the lung reduced in size, and more recently another CT scan
with contrast and sizes now. We had again reduced the illness to say they're very happy with it.
So praise God, that is just a super blessing. So I just I always say I don't think the
rife is a magic wand, but it's just why would you not try it and add it to your care?
Should my husband take the supplements that I have that are antioxidants that
I can't take, say that should my husband take the supplements that have antioxidants
during his chemo. Okay, so this is somebody asking for their husband who is a patient.
No, yes and no. So if you have supplements that have a small amount of antioxidants in them,
I don't see that they're going to necessarily be a big problem during the chemo. Plus,
my feeling is, if you look at our chemo protocol on our site and on the
Weber site, it talks about just eliminated antioxidants for the 48 hours. So the 48 hour window
after chemo. So I'm going to do chemo Monday at nine o'clock in the morning. I'm done at
11 o'clock with my infusion. I'm not going to start taking antioxidants again until Wednesday and
11 o'clock. So that's the 48 hour window post chemo that you would eliminate antioxidants.
If you have a supplement with a little bit of tumoric in it, can you still take it?
The argument is yes, you possibly can. There's naturopathic oncologist out there and there's
lots of articles out there that tell people to forget that whole thing. You should take
antioxidants through, you know, don't even use a 48 hour window. My point is, my belief is that
well, I mean, since chemo is a very oxidizing agent, you don't want to negate the effects of chemo.
So I would not take at least high dose antioxidants for that 48 hour window. I want that chemo
to work best as possible. So some people believe because they just understand that it's not always
black and white at all this stuff, right? I mean, there's literally very few things
in the practice of healthcare that are black and white. Everybody is different. Everybody is
unique. Some people do better taking high dose antioxidants, even while they're doing the chemo,
and it's protective of their healthy cells. And it doesn't seemingly do anything to negate
the effects of chemotherapy. And some people could. My position is this, you just don't know
if that what's going to work for you. And if you're going to do chemo, then I'd give that 40
in a window. But we've had people that have really, really had a horrible, horrible effects of chemo
therapy, gotten super deathly sick, and then my position might change in that particular case,
that it might be better if they continue with antioxidants to protect their healthy cells during that
I spend quite a lot of time outdoors and pre-cancer my go-to bug solution was DEET. I'm very
good for us, right? Bugs eat me alive, and I miserable with bites all summer. I'll be ordering some
of your bug spray. But for now, I'm managing the itch with bended drill and roll-on light okay.
Any concerns with my itch remedies? Well, any medication you use can have negative effects, right? So,
I can't really legally comment on those medications, but if you could Google the negative effects of
bended drill, then that would be good. I'd say there's probably a lot less negative effects of something
that is a topical of you're not going to have certainly, you know, anywhere close to 100%
from absorption. So, you know, it's going to stay topical for a large part too. So, but certainly
Google those that would help you understand that. I will say that the bug spray that we use and we have
the recipe online somewhere too on one of our blog posts really does work. It's pretty cool. So,
there's other things that you could do if you're really highly susceptible to bugs.
So, bugs bite and affect the buccoso membrane and the effect that you have from bugs is a histamine
reaction. It's a mast cell reaction. So, it's a one mast cells are one part of your immune system that
are in the buccoso membranes. And so, if you get this horrible reaction to bugs, you're getting a
horrible mast cell histamine reaction to bugs bug. So, taking some nutritional antihistamines can
be good for you. They come things like our natural clear hiss. They come things like our clear histamine
scavenger. They can be they can be really helpful to calm down that mast cell reaction. People that
have H and M T gene defects are going to be more susceptible to bug bites as well. There's other
natural things like taking garlic or taking B2, I think it is. Maybe it's B1. I don't know. You have
to Google it. It's thought to be it's kind of kind of old remedy for decreasing us, you know,
susceptibility to bug bites. So, there's think of those kind of things too. Anything you could do
naturally to help ward off your either a reaction to the mosquito bikes and stuff or be your
fact that bugs find you delicious. Can the gerson diet lower your white blood cell count? If so,
what should I be doing to get it back? So, my answer to that would be probably duct. So, I
there. The gerson diet is typically you are juicing, you're taking some good nutrition,
you're doing coffee animals. There is nothing in that that would lower your white blood cell count.
You know, one of the best things you could do to stimulate white blood cell count is to do coffee
animals because you're stimulating the parasympathetics, which are stimulating your immune response.
Anything that you're taking for an immune stimulant, which is typically things that we are,
we have recommended for your cancer will help build your white blood cell count.
So, when a person has low white blood cells, that's the side of immune compromise.
And that could be from a long-standing disease like a cancer that is just beating up your immune system.
Very common to have a lower in white blood cell count with autoimmune diseases. That's one
side of an autoimmune disease is a lower in white blood cell count. But you build it up by using
immune stimulants, which are the things that we need to give you for your deal with cancer.
Mushrooms are a great way to build white blood cell because mushrooms are more in immune
modulator. Things like vitamin C, vitamin D is an immune modulator as well, could help balance
your white blood cell count too. I saw there's a homeopathic remedy of the storm for a contrast
die for MRIs. Is there one for CT scan contrast, not for the contrast, but for the radiation.
So, we have a radiation homeopath. We don't have a CT die contrast
because I don't have any way of getting a sample of that contrast die to make a homeopath
on that. So, we don't have the contrast for CT scan. Last few days, my lab on my breast has been pink
and like a goose egg and has been a very sore last night. I started a targeted therapy for my
ecologist. Does this mean that the black sap is out of the question? I so wanted to get these
cells out of the out of the tumor with the black sap and out of my body with the black sap.
Yeah, most likely I would suggest you stay with that targeted therapy and see
do one thing at a time and see if that is going to be
beneficial first. Black sap is a big step and that's a big commitment and it's not something we
recommend for very many people. So, I would say let's stay with what they are saying, what they are
asking to. Understand if you have a pink reaction at the cancer, a reddit, a heat reaction at the
cancer. That's not always bad. That's an immune reaction. So, that could actually be a good thing.
You're getting an immune targeted reaction at the cancer. That's what you want. See what? The immune
system to attack a cancer. So, if you're getting redness, this is where that one blog post about
good pain, bad pain, this can be a good sign even though, oh my gosh, it might even cause pain.
So, no, I wouldn't think of this as a negative thing. Today, after I did my footpath, I realized
that I failed to unplug the red and black connectors for the bulb. I switched the toggle, switched
footpath and the unit seemed to work like normal but did I do any harm to my unit by not unplugging
the bulb? No, actually, you did exactly what you're supposed to do. You're not supposed to unplug
the bulb. So, do not unplug the bulb when you do your footpath. Leave the bulb plugged in.
So, we have some videos on that that explain that. But, make sure you leave the bulb plugged in.
I mean, if you unplug the bulb, you, you know, 99% of the time you won't hurt the machine,
but you can get an arc between those two things, those two inputs for the bulb inputs.
And true rife recommends you keep the bulb plugged in when you do the footpath.
Make sure you toggle switch it to footpath, just like you said, and you're running the footpath
programs. The biggest reason why a person eaters their rife machine is they will run a footpath
program not toggling it to footpath so they'll run it through the bulb or they'll run a
bulb program through the footpath. So, they'll toggle it to footpath. They'll turn on the,
they'll put the footpath plug in the footpath. They'll put it in the water. And they're running
not a footpath program, but a bulb program. You can blow a fuse. That's what you'll do.
Worst case scenario, you'll blow the transistor. That's that silver thing that you have to on the back
of your rife. You'll blow one of those transistors. Usually you have to do it for a period of time
before you can do that, but those are the most common mistakes at how you'll injure your rife.
Pretty much anything you do to the rife short of throwing it out of a 10-story building is very
fixable though. So, it's not that delicate that you injure at that point. So,
is there a tumor marker test for brain tumors? Mike's first MRI following chemo and radiation
showed something there, but it's the first scan post treatments. They don't know whether the,
whether it's tumor again or from radiation, meaning they're looking at it. Good thing that they're
thinking this way as possibly a pseudo tumor. He's feeling more fatigued again, so I'm suspicious
that it's re-grilled. Unfortunately, there isn't really any tumor markers for brain cancers. I mean,
understand that tumor markers can be for any cancers. But if you look at the research out there,
you really don't, you really don't run tumor markers for brain cancers because you're not,
they're not going to show positive. So, there really isn't, that's not a choice.
You're, you're going to stuck with MRI CT scan for your choices.
So, maybe follow-up with your radiologist about that. I don't know what they're asking
the next step to do, but I had paid in my chest at a dry cough for five months by family doctor,
doctor, order chest x-ray. It suggested possible pneumonia at possible metastasis in the lungs.
He prescribed a five-day antibiotic at another chest x-ray in a week. I am taking pre-biotic this
evening in the evening. If it is metastasis, should I change my regimen? Is a CT scan an intelligent
choice or overly damaging? May the King of Kings bless you and keep you. Thank you for caring for us.
Thank you for that blessing. First of all, your family doctor did a good thing. You're going to
order it at chest x-ray. And I think it was a wise thing to not just jump on the bad way and say
it's definitely metastasis. You could end pneumonia. So, that's probably a correct thing to order
an antibiotic. Excuse me. And do another chest x-ray. Let's do an antibiotic. Do another chest x-ray
at a week. I think your doctor is being very wise. But he's also being very wise saying this is possible
metastasis given that you have cancer. Should you change your regimen? Well, first of all, you
shouldn't change your right regimen because you're still treating a metastasis to another organ.
So, honestly, I don't know who asked this question. But let's say they have breast cancer,
possible metastasis to the lungs. It's still breast cancer in the lungs. It's not now lung cancer.
So, you're still running breast cancer frequencies. You're not running now changing your right
program to run lung cancer frequencies. Excuse me. It doesn't mean that you wouldn't run other things
for your lungs, but it doesn't mean that you might not want to change your nutritional regimen.
So, it would be wise to get a cheek swab done. So, send it a cheek swab.
And we can check and see if we need to do any tweaking of your nutrition. Because there's
different way you might, if there's metastasis in the lung, maybe we should wait and find out. If there
is metastasis in the lung, then we do another cheek swab. Let's just wait on that.
There's some different nutrition that can help with lung issues to
separate the comorbidities that you'd have with a tumor in the lung. So, we'd want to look at that.
Our borax and lye safe as ingredients and soaps.
I've not done any research on this and I saw this question and it was short enough that I read it.
And I do apologize. A lot of these questions I don't have time to read until this
tell our Zoom call. And that's why I don't always have answers for all of these. And I don't
have an answer for this. I would assume that there are probably harmful things in both of those.
Just because they have been used for a century, borax, or lye, to make soap doesn't necessarily mean
that they're actually safe or good for us. Um, the boracural chrome was a drug they used for centuries.
It's a mercury-based drug that they stopped, I think, until the 50s. And it was causing
course horrible issues. So, um, this is something you just have to google. I'm sorry, I don't have the
answer to that. I read the book How to Starve your Cancer by James McLelland. She talks about
blocking the pathways, um, uh, to the nutrients of the cancer cell, the cancer cells use with off-label
drugs. Do you think this is important along with diet and supplements? We have a number of patients
that are also doing, uh, this is called the care ecology approach. We have a number of patients
that are doing this approach along with everything that we're doing. I don't, I don't, I don't see
anything wrong with it, um, except that you need to do your old due diligence at google the side
effects of these drugs too. They're mainly fairly, um, common drugs like using, um, diabetes drugs to
decrease blood sugar, using it in an antibiotic. Of course, that has probably a lot of side effects,
because it's just damaging your microbiome. There's literally research coming out on a daily basis
on the microbiome of the body, not just the gut that is, uh, component to just about every disease.
So, there's side effects of these things. I'm sure that there's people that have done that approach
with great success. And it's really hated with their cancer. Certainly, if I was, if my cancer
was ployed in the wrong direction, and I try to do everything naturally, I would look at this
approach from Jay McClellan as well. So, um, I think there could be a lot of wisdom in that.
Oops, I had that question in there twice. Okay, now your questions from your, um, chat.
How many milligrams of B-17 should I take daily? Well, the answer to that is we didn't recommend B-17.
You're just going to have to make that decision. Typically, B-17 comes in capsules of the 100 milligrams
or 500 milligram capsules. Understand B-17 has, um, has a toxic effect
as well, taken into high dose. It could make you sick. So, I would do my due diligence and make sure
that your due doubt take too much of that. Um, it's, um, I would start with something, I would start with
the 100 milligram capsule and work your way up if you do want to choose that. If that's not something
we recommended, that's going to be, have to be something that's going to be your choice.
Uh, the last while I've felt, um, very weak and wobbly, um, on my feet, I've also felt light headed.
On Sunday, in emergency, blood work revealed very low ratings for potassium, hemoglobin, and blood
circulated, iron, iron storage was good. The doctor prescribed slow release potassium, which has brought,
which has brought the, in better balance. She also prescribed iron later. I thought about the fact
that cancer can feed on iron. I'm in a dilemma as to whether the iron man's will feed my breast tumors
and make my cancer progress. My tumors continue to grow anyway despite various interventions.
Um, so I think the doctor did a good job in giving you potassium. I think you do need to look at the
iron that she's given you, um, for two reasons. Number one, even a good source of iron can feed the cancer.
Um, but the, uh, iron that is prescribed, um, 99% of the time is ferrous sulfate, and that is a
really poor source of iron and it can cause got issues. It's not well absorbed and, um, it can actually
have some toxicity issues. I would not use ferrous sulfate, it would not use, um, any prescribed
iron. If you're going to use iron, um, use a good natural source of iron, we have a couple in our store.
Secondly, if you're going to use iron, know that there's a catch 22 by iron is low. So, um,
when you have low iron and low hemoglobin is called anemia. So the anemia that cancer patients have
has a name. It's called anemia of chronic disease. And in this case, it's from cancer and anemia
in cancer with cancer patients can be because the cancer is goblet up the iron causing the anemia.
So then you're kind of at a catch 22. Well, if I take iron, well, then I'm just basically feeding the
cancer. But if I don't take iron, I have this anemia, and that is not good for me either because we,
you know, I have fatigue. I have no energy. I can't get my oxygen to my tissues because that's
what hemoglobin does. So it carries oxygen, um, to the tissues and it is, um, very important. Iron is
a very important component of that. So you're in a catch 22. So one theory is that there's certain
nutrients that can follow iron. Artimistic it is one, um, the, um, beta glucans is another thing. So
mushrooms can follow iron. Those that some theories that are out there. So we typically tell you if
you have to take iron, use our iron, artimistic in protocol, um, on our website or if you're taking,
already taking a low via immune or you're taking a mushroom, then I'll take it with your mushroom
or the low via immune or artimistic in it. Burberry can also follow iron. So if you're taking
burberry, take it with your burberry, um, but you're kind of at a catch 22. I need to increase my
iron, but iron can feed the cancer. What do you do? I mean, you, you've got to make a decision to,
to boost your iron. But certainly if you're going to take iron, take a good natural source of it. It's
not going to damage your gut as well. We have a really good, um, liquid iron. That's, um, that's
an herbal components to it as well. And we have an iron, ferrous by, by glycinate, by glycinate.
And that is a double bonded iron to a glycine molecule that's the way we found in plates.
And that is our
reacted iron or it's called our clear iron. So that's the iron that I'm going to take.
Uh, is aspirin okay for the days I have pain or is it harmful?
I am so sorry, I have a scratchy syrup. Well, like any medication, it could have its negative things
just because it's an old medication does not necessarily mean it's a goodie. All these are not always
goodies, right? So I can't legally tell you to take aspirin or to not take aspirin just like I can't
legally tell you to take, you know, any drug that's out there. Aspirin does have the side effect, um,
increasing the possibility of bleeding. So if a person is taking aspirin, you know, a lot of aspirin,
especially they're going to have a higher radar chance of developing, you know, stomach issues,
bleeding issues, blood thinning issues, which can be maybe what they're shooting for. So it
depends on exactly what is going on with that person. Maybe they do need some blood thinning issues
and that's what they're going to choose to take. Of course, any of the other drugs like,
over-the-counter pain medications like Tylenol and Advil could have, you know, maybe even worse issues.
So that will have to be something that you'd have to take up with your medical doctor from a legal
standpoint or do your own research and maybe ask for it as the best thing for you and the least
of all the bad things that are out there. Other things that you could do for pain from a natural
perspective is, you know, you start with the flavonoids, the curcumin, the resveratrol, the green T
extract, the white willow bark that buzzwellia, the steened edels, things like that. Well, those certainly
are good for milder amounts of pain, lower grain pain because what they do is they decrease inflammation
and often pain has an inflammatory component. The good thing about those things is they're pretty
much good for everybody and you really can't ody on them. So the bad thing is, is they don't really,
they aren't really effective. They're certainly not as effective as a medication for high levels,
higher levels of pain. When the only thing that can work from a natural perspective for a higher
level of pain, maybe like a use of a THC marijuana, but then that has other side effects too. So
it's not legal everywhere and it can make you really low B, but a person with constant pain
that can be an option as well that doesn't do well with pain meds. So hopefully I answered that
question for you. Some days I get started late with my supplements which then pushes all of my doses
back. I understand the importance of rest and recovery while sleeping. What are your thoughts about
taking supplements close to bedtime? Is it too hard at my liver when it's supposed to be resting,
healing detoxified? Ideally, I wouldn't be in the situation, but if it happens, would you say to skip
the dose or to take it? That's a good question. There isn't anything wrong with skipping the dose,
especially if, so I would say it really depends on the person. So if you feel like
it's going to give you a tummy ache because you're not taking it with food, you're taking it right
before bed, hand or if you feel like it's going to keep you awake in any way, then I would say skip
the dose. If you're like, no, that's not an issue at all. Well then you can certainly take it too.
So there's an entire concept. Paul scene supplements that I've talked about dozens of times on these
Zoom calls and I'm pretty sure I have a blog post about it. There can be benefit to taking a day off
your supplements just to kind of give your body a rest so that there can be benefits to that. So
there certainly isn't a negative of taking an evening off, so I don't think there's anything wrong
with skipping the dose. Any other questions? Okay, well, but that will bid a due and hope your day
goes well. Looks like we're supposed to get some rain the next couple days, which is well-needed as
well here in Wisconsin, Minnesota area. So I pray that you guys have a blessed day. Remember to
continue to add your questions to the pages, the members only site and keep looking at the members
only site because we're updating, changing, tweaking, improving. His best we possibly can to
make our services as appropriate as we can to everybody. With that, I know I'll be praying for you and
we cherish your prayers for us. You guys have a blessed day.